life sucks in bear country just had a
cruise Lee with two cubs coming at me
from about 80 yards and I sprayed the
out of her with bear spray
she got my head good I don't know what's
under my hat my ear my arm pieces of
stuff hanging out I don't know what's
going on in there I think my arms broke
but legs are good internal organs are
good eyes are good I just walked out
three miles now you go to the hospital
so be safe out there by God's grace his
life and iPhone were spared the guy
whose head is being held together by an
adjustable cap is Todd and a bear almost
put him into permanent hibernation twice
the speed of Usain Bolt more killer
instinct than a white male high school
loner with no father figure plus 4-inch
claws and hot salmon burps it's no
surprise bears caused nearly two deaths
a year in the United States the only
safe bears gummy and not those
sugar-free ones they'll rip your
butthole worse than that bear who won
DiCaprio has sympathy Oscar
was that movie Ted - if you encounter a
bear in the wild you should punch it in
the nose that might be advice for a
short but at least you'll die with the
Bears respect when a grizzly is chomping
on your skull even Peter recommends you
blow his goddamn head off I realize most
folks watch this show for important
wilderness survival tips but we like to
laugh at people who've been seriously
injured as well that's why I'm invited
that mangled mountain man to finally
answer the question does a bear
pieces of Todd in the woods for this
week's web Redemption welcome to my
Stabbin cabin rest easy
I've taken every precaution to keep the
Bears at bay I appreciate that nice to
meet you Dan you know Oh getting here
for a bear hug or that put you in a bad
place trigger warning Todd thank you for
being here thank you
how you doing I'm doing well mostly
healed lots of scars but I'm doing well
how many views does your video have I
don't know what it is now but it had 39
million views in like 48 hours I was
just gonna send the video to a couple
buddies I'm like well I got a couple
other friends it'll just be easier to
throw it on Facebook and then all of a
sudden two hours later my phones blowing
up my email is blowing up I'm getting
thousands of messages and yeah it was
insane how often have you seen bears
before this moment you're like commonly
I work in the woods I recreative you I
work for the Forest Service okay I do
all their trails engineering do bears
actually hibernate that seems fake they
do depends on where they're at all right
I just seems to you can't just not eat
for three months it seems crazy are you
suffering PTSD from this I'm not I've
never had any bear dreams or any
nightmares or any issues a little more
anxious nervous back in the woods
obviously for the record what are we
supposed to do when we encounter a black
bear versus a grizzly bear a grizzly
bear if it attacks you you're you want
to play dead you don't want to run
because that triggers that predator-prey
response and they're going to chase you
black bears are a little different you
may want to try to fight it off what are
you supposed to doing for polar bears
say your prayers I think yeah I mean you
did do the one cardinal sin when a bear
attacks and that's not reach for your
phone and start filming
had I known the video is gonna go viral
and we would have been sitting on some
gold yes don't worry I'm in show
business and I made a 100% accurate
reenactment video I just need you to
walk us through what happened well it
was a Saturday morning and I wanted to
get out there's a couple weeks before
hunting season and I wanted to get just
a heads up the part of you is being
played by three hot chicks in bikinis
that's what we're currently doing here
in Hollywood gender-bending the roles
for the ladies and told it's empowering
okay hope they scissor well it was a
Saturday morning and I wanted to get out
there's a couple weeks before hunting
season and so I get about three miles up
the trail at the far end of the meadow
about 80 yards is a grizzly bear Sal
with two cubs
female grizzly bear is called a Sal Sal
yes now how do you know that it's not
like a single father raising his kids
father's do not raise the Cubs it's
always with the South you think with the
current me to movement and everything
that maybe the father's would ship or
maybe yeah but no huh interesting she
runs over the ridge disappears I thought
all right she's gone that way I'll go to
off the trail and continue my day and
I'll never see her again I took a few
steps heard a noise and she had circled
it around the ridge and came in behind
me charging
like how long of a time is like a minute
she had covered a couple hundred yards
dropped her cubs here too and then came
by herself back around behind me and
she's coming straight down the hill
going through the brush the grass is
flying hold my bear spray pulled the
safety out thinking it's probably just a
bluff charge but just in case gonna have
it ready in that two seconds she had
already covered that distance in all
since she's on top of me
and she bit me like five times in my
right arm now they fight and tear or
just fight and let go and bite she was
just just mostly just biting and letting
go you feel like Marv Albert at this
point no you would feel like the hooker
Marv Albert used to bite hookers in the
back didn't you continue like five
seconds and she was gone and I'm
thinking wow I was lucky I just survived
a grizzly bear attack and I looked I got
you know arms bleeding and like all
right time to go to the hospital and get
some stitches so I start down the trail
and all of a sudden I hear just
something behind me makes me turn and
that bear come off the ridge and she's
like ten feet behind me now and she's
coming wide open again into charge and
there was no time ahead bear spray in my
hand pistol here no time to even turn I
just protect my vitals I don't even know
what vitals are okay so what it what is
there just just soft part of your
stomach that they can tear into but then
your neck is a bad spot I could be bad
egg just one swipe this time she's
really mad the first bite was in my left
arm and I heard the crunch of the bone
where she broke my arm I mean I can see
a divot there that's where the tendons
were sticking out she ripped two tendons
loose this whole part of my forum was
just kind of shredded from the teeth so
I just told myself I'm like you got to
play dead you have to hold still or
she's going to continue chewing on you I
can't even stay still if when I'm
getting a massage at a spa if they start
applying just a little bit of mild
pressure
I'm just squirming it's amazing what
your body can do when you're in a
survival situation I just blocked out
the pain but all my other senses are
heightened I can hear the crunching of
like her canine teeth going into the
muscle pick me up shake me slam me back
down how long is this attack probably a
couple minutes but it felt like hours
and one of her claws kept aside of my
scalp my scalp was hanging over my ear
since my eyes are filled with blood got
a broken arm tendon sticking out and
then the bear just stops and she just
kind of sniff in the back of my neck and
that was the eeriest part of the whole
thing is to actually feel and hear her
breath right on the back of my neck just
sitting there going oh please leave
please leave don't move
Holt trying to hold my breath and then
she just stood there for like thirty
seconds not moving I'm guessing she's
kind of looking around and I'm just like
trying not to breathe trying to not make
a sound it all since she just stepped
off and disappeared and I'm like I have
to get out of here so I wiped the blood
from my eyes kind of looked each
direction she wasn't there that was not
really was it worth it for the story no
it was not I still wish you two pulled
the gun instead of the bear spray I
think I would still pull bear spray
first 99% of the time that's gonna turn
him I know but welcome to the one
percent yeah exactly it's a good well
I've been in it for a while I'm sorry
about this Todd
what'd I tell you guys no Bears allowed
I'm into otters truthfully twinks prey
doesn't work on bears but it sure does
rile them up
if you don't know the difference between
an honor and a bear head over to West
Hollywood and ask a park ranger we'll be
right back but first
you